[Music]
foreign
should touch down at the resorts Town
two weeks of sun Sea and Sand await you
you're going on holiday
suddenly your plane starts losing
altitude
Earth and Sky switch places the flight
crashes end of story
or is it
it was just a dream a simulation Pilots
train in simulation cockpits like these
now when you see an empty screen instead
of the ground coming up to meet you it's
obvious that it's not real but when the
plane began to fall the fear of death
felt real or the same right
what actually is real anyway
everyone has asked themselves these
questions and at some points even
doubted the reality of reality but
further reflection always leads to
disturbing conclusions and unanswered
questions and therefore mostly people
play by the rules
and they do not go beyond the boundaries
of what is allowed in this game
this game has no name
this video was created by the some
sub-verification platform but more about
sums up in a bit
it's sort of like having an Apple Watch
or a Fitbit uh we're replacing a piece
of skull with like a
you know a smart watch here is one of
the richest people in the world
demonstrating the possibilities of
neuraling Technology
a ship has been implanted in the
primate's brain with the help of which
the monkey plays ping pong on the screen
using just the power of thought
for this he gets a fruit smoothie the
technology that musk so strongly
believes in should help disabled people
for example to control a biomechanical
prosthetic
the monkey obviously doesn't think about
the mechanisms that allow its mind to
change the image on the monitor
it doesn't feel the implanted electrodes
it just happens organically as it thinks
I think therefore I am
Rene Descartes fundamental principle is
well known it is one of the main
Thoughts with which modern European
philosophy began
a French thinker proposed a thought
experiment known as Descartes demon how
can we prove that everything we see feel
and imagine isn't just a delusion of a
powerful evil spirit
and the answer is we can't the only
thing that we cannot be tricked into
believing is that we exist even if our
entire Consciousness is literally placed
in a jar the possibility of the
existence of our Consciousness in
isolation from the physical body and
even the physical world has long been a
source of inspiration for writers of
Science Fiction
but more recently scientists have
actually managed to restore some brain
functions after its removal
the brains it's true with that of a pigs
but still
but why should we remain slaves to
biology we can go one step further for
example to digitize our entire
Consciousness brain activity is
essentially a huge number of weak
electrical impulses ones and zeros we
already have a pretty good idea of how
our brain works so why not create a
virtual copy of it on a machine the
digital brain is a simulation of
human-like processing that can interact
with you konnichiwa I'm Yumi
so far this seems impossible scientists
say that the brain is constantly in
multiple different states it cannot be
described by our current understanding
of mathematics and here we return to the
Cartesian demon if we understand that
life outside the body is possible at
least in theory how can we be sure that
we are not already in a simulation
and here's another amusing argument that
we are in The Matrix because even the
highest quality photo can be enlarged to
only one pixel all the way down to a
square listen in the real world we can
zoom down to see bacteria and viruses
then to the level of atoms quarks and
superstrings which are the bits and
pieces that make up the whole image of
reality
but like a computer screen our reality
too has a limit do you remember how do
you define real
if you're talking about what you can
feel what you can smell what you can
taste and see then real is simply
electrical signals interpreted by your
brain but this has been derived from an
idea from thousands of years ago
the original is Plato's Cave
Millennia before wachovsky's film The
Greek philosopher had already formulated
The Matrix paradox he proposed a thought
experiment
several prisoners are chained up in a
cave and have been since childhood their
eyes are directed at a wall and there is
a fire burning behind them people and
animals pass in front of the flame carry
objects but the inhabitants of the cave
can only see Shadows on the wall
for them these Shadows make up the whole
world
at some point one prisoner is released
he goes outside and sees that the
Shadows are just reflections of real
objects returning to the cave he tries
to tell the other prisoners about it but
they don't believe him they think that
he has gone mad I have you lost your
mind cause I'll help you find it so the
next step is to ask the question what if
there is no world outside the cave and
the wall the flame the shackles and
Plato himself live in our Consciousness
how can we prove that the world really
exists but it exists somewhere else
besides in our heads solipsism asserts
that you can't
this is a philosophical Trend that
argues that it's impossible to refute
the idea of a phenomenal World a
universe that is born only from
experience
when we look at the Shadows on the wall
they are real but as soon as we look
away the Shadows cease to exist in the
universe
a tree falls beside you you hear the
sound of it falling and you can clearly
say that a tree has fallen a similar
tree falls on a remote desert island but
there's no one around to hear it
reality appears only when it has a
subject someone who can perceive this
reality
you don't hear the sound of it falling
therefore the tree did not fall and
hence the tree does not exist in this
world
what if everything we feel and perceive
is just part of a simulation
if we don't hear a falling tree on the
other side of the earth why are we so
sure that the echo nearby is real
yes we can't be sure whether the echo
next to us is real or not but there are
some things that we have to be certain
about
with Rising fraud identity theft and
criminal activity in general the
survival of your business hinges on your
ability to verify that's why companies
all over the world make an effort to
check the identities of their customers
which is where some sub comes in our
unique verification solution allows
businesses to verify users from more
than 220 countries and territories with
a high conversion rate you can build
flexible verification flows to balance
compliance fraud prevention and user
experience
some sub can provide everything from
Identity and address verification to
transaction monitoring
with us you can stop worrying about
identity theft accounts takeovers
synthetic fraud and other illegal
activities
follow the link to some subs free demo
below
meet Nick Bostrom note in foil has no
crazy look in his eyes the Swedish
scientist is probably the main modern
theorist of transhumanism a researcher
of the dangers of artificial
intelligence but perhaps his most famous
work is the 2003 article are you living
in a computer simulation
the text is considered as a reference
reasoning about the likelihood that we
will all see a machine-generated
collective dream simulation by the way
Elon Musk believes in Boston's Theory
in short Bostrom put forward three basic
assumptions
or as they are sometimes called the
theory of three doors
the first is that simulation is
impossible because no civilization will
be able to reach such a high level of
development most likely it would destroy
itself before reaching that point
the second is an advanced civilization
if it is able to develop the technology
to simulate the world it wouldn't use
them for religious or ethical reasons
and the third assumption is that we are
almost definitely living in a computer
simulation
it argues that the belief that there is
a significant chance that we will one
day become post-humans who run ancestor
simulations is false unless we are
currently living in a simulation if the
first two possibilities do not obtain
then there will be many many more
simulated people like us then there will
be non-simulated people like us in other
words
almost all people with our kinds of
experiences would be living inside
simulations rather than outside them but
what technologies does a civilization
have to possess in order to simulate the
whole world
how much power would a computer need
after all the simulation would have to
render not only the visible reality
surrounding us but also every neuron of
every brain that has ever lived
this concept is also called the
Matryoshka brain it's a huge computer
the size of the solar system here's what
a computer Mega brain might look like
the concept is beautiful but
unrealizable firstly the creation of a
mega computer will require more
resources than Humanity currently has at
its disposal and there are serious
questions about whether such an object
can exist in principle
and secondly this solution is a bit
excessive why render Everything at Once
remember how computer games work well
the object is on the periphery of the
scene or far off on the horizon its
shape is roughly represented and it's
only as the character gets closer but
the details are becoming visible most
likely the simulation we're living in
tries to economize energy in some way
we know that the world is made up of
atoms and molecules we know that there
is bacteria everywhere but we can only
see them in a microscope
the Mega processor doesn't need to
constantly render the entire universe it
generates only the area on which our
Consciousness pays attention this is the
principle of quantum superposition a
picture of reality will exist as long as
it has an observer it's a
technologically provable solipsism and
if Humanity can learn to create such
simulations we'll be able to spot the
glitches in our reality that prove that
we ourselves live in The Matrix
this is the 2016 game no man's Sky it is
literally an infinite number of
procedurally generated worlds with each
one appearing only when the player
decides to explore it a complex Universe
where thousands of stars moons and
players exist simultaneously at all this
complexity the entirety of this Brave
New World was created by just one Studio
but we are also shown what the microcosm
looks like with its bacteria and viruses
only when our character decides to look
through the microscope or that Pilots
see rendered Runway lights when it's
Landing time
one Professor often addressed students
with a half joke look gentlemen how
convenient a cat has holes on its skin
exactly where its eyes are some suspect
that the world is literally created for
us this is called the anthropic
principle we observe the universe as it
is because only in such a universe could
an observer such as ourselves arise
have you ever wondered how the world
hangs in such a delicate delicate
balance absolutely ideal for our species
our planet isn't too close to the Sun
but also not too far away there is the
right level of oxygen and relatively
infrequent volcanic eruptions in
tsunamis
all fundamental constants are located in
a narrow window of possible deviations
at which in principle our universe could
appear if the force of mutual
gravitation attraction of material
bodies was just a little more intense
then the expansion would stop almost
before it could begin and the world
would literally shrink back into a
structuralist mass before it could
really even be born
it's quite possible that millions and
billions of other universes really
couldn't exist for any notable length of
time perhaps in thousands of other
worlds the balance of power didn't
facilitate the creation of life
it's certainly plausible if you flip a
coin 10 times in a row the probability
that it will land on heads 10 times in a
row is 1024. that is out of 1024 rounds
of tossing a coin 10 times in a row on
average you will achieve a result in
which the coin will consistently fall
one side up all 10 times in a row just
once
in exactly the same way out of the
countless possible universes only a few
have a chance of having a set of
fundamental constants that will allow
them to develop in a favorable for their
further sustainable development way
that is we live in the very rarest case
of probability Theory or the whole world
was literally invented to be a place of
human life
scientists argue how inevitable the
appearance of a thinking organism was
anthropologists proved that our species
was one of the many competing species of
hominids the Neanderthals and any
servants disappeared
yes even our ancestors passed through
the bottleneck many times
just a few thousand remained of the
population but Humanity survived an
amazing phenomenon in terms of
probability and now there are billions
of us the coin has landed on heads
countless times
you just need enough of the world that
they see around nothing that they see
around them right so you want to start
digging and that's so funny and I
haven't put the Earth there is this
there's a flag that goes up in the
programmer and they say up need more
Earth so you put Earth beneath you while
you can keep digging let's go back to
Bostrom such computers would be virtual
machines a familiar Concept in computer
science virtual machines can be stacked
it's possible to simulate a machine
simulating another 12 machines and so on
in arbitrarily many steps of iteration
so now that world
evolves and they develop computing power
right and they say we want to play video
games so now we're going to make a world
so then they make a world and they have
sufficient computing power that they
invent right to create a whole universe
within their computers okay and then
they make a world and then they make a
world all the way on down well you get
the picture once again it's this
principle of the Matryoshka doll each
simulation created will sooner or later
reach a level that allows it in turn to
launch its own virtual Universe every
creation is a creator for someone but
for whom are all these worlds created
who will populate them and most
importantly why would an advanced
post-human civilization run lots of
simulations
why do you think your people made me
made you guys were good
can you imagine how disappointing would
be for you to hear the same thing from
your creator
the superhumans of the future developed
an artificial intelligence so great that
the machine was able to construct a
Whole Living World
Ostrom naming a civilization that could
potentially launch a simulation ancestor
among other things suggested that the
purpose of such a project could be to
study one's own past
would you refuse to see in real time how
the heroes of antiquity lived what they
talked about Caesar Macedonian Plato the
civilization of the future just wants to
see its roots another option is for
entertainment there's nowhere left to go
nowhere
[Music]
except the always
a whole virtual universe that is our
world is not a simulation for us but a
game Universe where our Advanced
descendants take part this raises a
disturbing question
in what capacity are we living in such a
simulation as NPCs therefore most of us
have such boring and eventless lives
we're just background dummies at the
next FIFA Stadium
tell me do you feel compassion for
characters in The Sims
by this Logic the real participants in
the events that is independent Minds
playing a simulation can be famous
people
well you know the whole RPG world
revolves around the main character until
geralt went to look for Siri nothing
happened why would we need Skyrim
without the main character and his
scream therefore take a closer look at
famous people some of them don't even
make much of an effort to disguise
themselves but it is going to bother you
as you're human and and I was human I am
human still or perhaps the civilization
of the future came up with this
imitation of reality in order to live in
the past
imagine that Humanity has reached the
height of technological advancement but
the planet's resources are depleted it
was not possible to find a new world
suitable for colonization
our descendants are tied to the dying
Earth why not immerse everyone in the
simulation choosing for it an era
preceding the post-human one
that is perhaps our physical bodies are
thousands of years ahead but our minds
live in the analog 21st century
but there are arguments against it here
is one of the best ones as you know like
Google engrams has a way to type in a
word and see how interesting a client
declines arises over time right yeah you
can just type in a year and get the
answer for that if you type in a
particular year like 1900 or 1950 you
can see with Google and Graham how
interesting that year increased up until
that date and decreased after it yep and
you can see that interest in a date
declines faster than does the population
grow with time
that is brilliant the man who formulated
this Paradox is Professor Robin Hansen
but we'll come back to him later so what
if the opposite is true we found a
distant potentially habitable World
After All a planet a hundred light years
away a huge ship is racing there at
sub-light speed and all the potential
migrants on board are immersed in sleep
and so that these inhabitants of the
interstellar Arc would not be bored in
an eternal sleep it was turned into a
simulation
that is we will all wake up one day
instantly forgetting about our Earthly
lives in order to set foot on another
planet
but our world is objectively too far
from Paradise if you really come up with
a recreational dream it could be nicer
and our reality very similar to well
prison what do you mean three weeks
if you just wait for a just
let's imagine the distant future again
the value of human life and freedom is
absolute but nature won't change people
will break the law and sometimes very
seriously but it will be impossible to
execute them or send them to jail for
the rest of their lives and then the
criminal gets sent into the simulation
to us from a world without Wars diseases
and inequality to our world here
it's quite possible depending on the
severity of the crime they change the
era the country the initial
opportunities
there is another possibility this whole
simulation is for you yes you
all other participants of the Matrix are
Bots
you are the only living participant
but you've been here too long
[Music]
when they talk about malfunctions in
simulations they often recall this
episode from The Matrix about deja vu
[Music]
oh deja vu
by the way when was the last time you
experienced this feeling
doctors still can't say exactly what
causes deja vu
in general they say it's to do with a
failure in the formation of short-term
memory the brain perceives a fresh newly
received impression as an old memory
but maybe this is a glitch you see an
event that you have already lived
through which was not completely erased
during the next reboot of the system
tell us what you think of your world
perhaps the simulated world is not as
big as we think distant countries the
moon the Mariana Trench do they exist
well the whole world is enclosed in a
small space where the same plots are
generated which we then forget about
we're inside the endless seasons of The
Simpsons that's why the cartoon often
predicts what will happen in the real
real the world the internet would not be
the internet if it did not assume that
the show is a simulation something like
The Truman Show but even the most
advanced simulation is imperfect
sometimes glitches more serious than
Deja Vu happen do you know what the
Mandela effect is the system is so
Advanced that it allows the participants
of the simulation to see their own flaws
but anyone who points out the glitches
in The Matrix is not erased he is
censored
who believes these flat earthers
foil-clad contactees or Global
conspiracy theorists belief in the
unreality of the world is another law by
which the Matrix lives we need to doubt
you are dead Don't Be Afraid follow the
path further is an approximate
translation of an inscription left in an
ancient Egyptian Crypt Then followed a
detailed algorithm for how the afterlife
double of the deceased can pass into the
other world clearly I'm in a certain ERA
with a certain kind of world around me
right so either this is a complete
fantasy or it's a past of somebody else
in the future Professor Robin Hansen has
written a modern guide for those who
think they are living in a simulation
the guide appeared shortly after
bostrom's article in short if you might
be living in a simulation then all else
equal it seems that you should care less
about others live more for today make
your world look Lively to become
eventually Rich expect and try to
participate in pivotal events be
entertaining and praiseworthy and keep
the famous people around you happy and
interested in you it's that simple even
if we live in a simulation there's
nothing we can do about it but even if
we find and someone may have found a way
out of the simulation what awaits us on
the other side
[Music]
[Applause]
it's unlikely to be the case let's put
it like that but our belief in the
illusory nature of the world around us
and a higher being from the distant
future isn't this a defense mechanism
it's nice to believe that the
environment is just another round of
simulator launch
believing in the simulation removes so
many problems cancels moral dilemmas
what's to take from a poor NPC and most
importantly when the plane Collies with
the ground it will be impossible to
relaunch the flight simulator
[Music]
to avoid interrupting the simulation
turn on the next video